you guys had a lot of situations on the
table
what was it about red bull music
because that caught a lot of people off
guard yeah what was it about the red
bull situation that you guys were like
this fits because it obviously worked it
was the first time you guys are the
first people to make that work yeah in
the hip-hop space for sure for sure um
it was a culmination of a couple of
things right like we understood what we
wanted from a business aspect
like if you look at eagle you could take
like
all money in opm
uh a tde
and
somebody's formula like a e40
and just combine all those together and
we just understood like one ownership
because blast was a producer as well so
we were already doing so much money in
merch and he was already doing enough
money on distrokid from his production
catalog and his artist catalog that it
was like
we ain't got to take twenty thousand
dollars right now because the [ __ ] can
make twenty thousand dollars in a month
just off his natural services that he
does as a creator right so that was how
we first stepped in the room two like i
said like most people don't expect
somebody to come in there and have an
educational conversation like especially
like a young black dude that's under 30
and has never worked in music before
because i never worked in music before
blast so me having these conversations
were like super raw anyway but shout out
to our lawyer our lawyer is 29 too and
so he professor at drexel university got
a sports firm got his own lawsuit
all that [ __ ] can we get can we get the
lawyers can we get a name drop on the
lawyer folks
shout
for
shout
the lawyer so
i mean just with us three walking in the
building together
it's kind of like you really crossed all
the t's and dot all the eyes with that
cause it's like you got your legal
assistance right here then you got me
who actually understands like business
structure business development and then
we came with an actual staff with actual
vision with a brand with color schemes
or already visuals put out so i already
know when you come to the table with
that much
it's really not much you can really give
us in that space it's more so just like
what you can throw with gas you could
throw in the flame that's already kind
of like heating up but overall i just
understood red bull is a privately owned
company so they're like they're not on
the stock market which means that if
they grossing 4 billion a year that
means they're doing something
right but lastly i did my my senior
dissertation on red bull because i wrote
my paper on vertical integration and red
bull is a marketing company
to start off it wasn't a energy drink so
that's where you see all these
advertisements all these events and all
that type of stuff just sources from
them being a marketing company so me
writing that paper i already understood
too like
we can make so much money that's
non-recupable
that is like we'll make more money in
our recruitable funds than advances just
because red bull got so much stuff i.e
the f1s um the events the extreme sports
games just skydiving all right
they're the airplane [ __ ] they got all
kinds of things
we get so much money off of
sync plays from internal red bull
sources that it's like we can make so
much money and just keep recouping every
advance by just deferring that of the
appearance fees we're getting so
the way that we can cut like cross
collateralizing most of the time is like
negative because it's like most people
going a whole from cross-collateralizing
whether it be like a producer
cross-collateralized with an artist or
however it goes
but in this sense
we crossing over between readable music
rare bull culture team red bull extreme
sports and we going through all these
different facets of red bull and we get
money with these different divisions but
all these different places got their own
ceos you know what i'm saying they all
their own different branches of red bull
all this [ __ ] is not under one mm-hmm so
you know just with breaking the artist
and understanding creativity and
understanding that blast was like a
super creative artist on top of
everything i was just like bro you
really need to go somewhere where
somebody can like tap into your talents
and actually bring your talents out like
have you designed some [ __ ] for the f1
speedway to where that [ __ ] gets
featured and then you get a royalty off
all this merch that's sold worldwide wow
so just that type of thingy